what's up everybody I am coming to the
Brea Improv I will be there October 13
14:15 outside Los Angeles we got a
Thursday we got a Friday Saturday Sunday
shows Christy comedy.com for Ticky
wikies then October 18th Lista Nevada
the 19th Kansas City the 20th St Louis
the 21st Hammond Indiana and then
October 26th to the 28th Raleigh North
Carolina the capital all tickets at
Chris DC comedy.com for the love of God
buy a goddamn ticket what's up guys real
quick tour dates are on sale right now
at salcano comedy.com uh there's tons of
cities up there tomorrow night if you're
watching us right now on hey bab
tomorrow night I am in Bowling Green
Kentucky on Friday Cincinnati on
Saturday and Toledo on Sunday there's
still some tickets available so get
those uh following that we're going to
be in wils Bear Pennsylvania and
Wilmington Delaware then we're doing mon
Savannah and Athens Georgia and so on
and so forth there's a big Illinois run
in November leading up to my comedy
special at the Vic in Chicago on
December 1st and 2nd the second sold out
as you guys I hopefully know uh and so
we edit two shows on the first all will
be taped and all if you have a ticket to
any of those shows you'll be eligible to
win uh a flight hotel and trip to the
set of Impractical Jokers I'm choosing
one ticket out of those four shows uh
December 1st is still on sale right now
but it's going fast savano comedy.com
hope to see you guys on the
road don't be fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey he hey heyab
hey it's Thursday and you know what that
means everyone loves hey babes now
scissor
man what's up everybody hello how's you
like Anthony Bowens one more time
scissor me Daddy ah I let's do it
oh you know wrestling uh I know old
school wrestling okay and I know the
rock I don't know the new guys I don't
really know so well yeah we uh we have
our our friend Anthony Bowen he he opens
up uh every podcast and uh he's famous
for a move uh where he's he's openly gay
wrestler which is which was uh I don't
think that has anything to do with the
scissoring though I feel like do you
think a straight guy would would scissor
I the way it came about was just them
messing around I think and then they
just ran with it remember the old school
stuff we were kids to do this yeah oh we
should say we have our friend and his
comedian Joe bartnik on with us today
what's happening s Chris how you doing
budy racially ambiguous Joe
bartnik well I'm half Italian half
mut yeah because you could be Middle
Eastern you could be Itali you could be
a French you should you should be an
actor because you can adapt I could see
all of it yes I am I but I'm always typ
cast you know I always do play in the
dying in some way like a deli worker or
a thug or but I can't I can only be
myself acting is hard just being
yourself which I think most actors are
just themselves a version of a version
of themselves I think like that's yeah
the best actors I think that they just
bring their mannerisms and quirks to any
um any uh character I I do you think
you're a good actor S I don't think so I
think in some instances yes and in some
instances absolutely not yeah we don't
think so
either
I I I've never actually seen you act but
see I would think that you would be a
good actor from all the work you've done
on the show that that would translate
nicely to acting in some instances I can
pull it off but in some I I I I feel
insecure and don't think I'm I'm good at
things I've never had like a lesson or
any training or anything like that the
really hardest thing about acting is
knowing the words good enough to act yes
and I have such low um memory skills the
whole time I'm just what are that are
the [__] words right so when I
finally know them right I'm okay it's
like anytime I'm acting where it's like
a thing where it's like a Larry i' not
been on a Larry David show but where
it's like just get to this kind of gist
and make sure you get this out then I'm
perfect too but when it's like I don't
talk like a regular person I don't use
sentences so it's like using a full sent
senten you know what I mean like even in
my ACT it's like I just talk in like
spurts so it's like a long run on
sentence it's like I run out of breath
right that's when I have the problem
when it's either like when it's like
something that's really specific and the
way it's written I I don't feel like
it's natural have a hard time there but
if you like let me improvise or
something then I'm better exactly it's
really hard to be natural when it's not
something you would be right right now
Joe's got a special out called a killing
in Chicago it's out right now and um was
yeah what was that the intro was just
hilarious that is the intro yeah can can
you put just put on yeah I was just I
was I was
watching so who's that guy to Kenny oh
this is so funny dude awesome
by the way we just can you restart it
can we we just but we moved if you if
you're wondering what's going on here we
we moved out of the other Studio cuz
there was construction going on and
there still is construction going on but
it's just not right outside our our wall
but uh you might still hear it but we
thought it' be be it be best for uh the
listener if we moved just give you a
little bit less construction noises so
bear with we could have canceled today
but we didn't want to so just make
believe it's part of the fun yes here we
go this is already the best intro to a
special I've ever seen in my entire life
thank you it really is I mean what a
mustache great mustache oh dude this is
unreal rock
[Music]
it cuz for as much as I want to say oh
specials are just about the jokes and
they are adding stuff like this that's
cool and dope and different makes me
already be I want to watch this thing
now I mean I love this I'm not just
saying that Joe's a guy you don't want
to fight no Joe's a guy you don't want
to fight that's just a man yeah you are
a regular man like you're a man when I
when I was little and I looked up like
and I and I looked up and I said oh look
at that man you're that man Joe was
stronger than the bolt of us when he was
seven yeah 100% you think he can beat up
club soda Kenny he's a big guy too no I
miss Club Kenny I almost died with that
Cadillac though like three times I
almost ran over with a crew really yeah
the brakes didn't work oh [__] look at
that there he is dude this is unreal
this was a I mean this is a to-do did
Bill Bird direct this uh no his buddy
directed my buddy Ben tishler shout out
Ben tishler happy yam kapor belated oh
that's so fun that's so good dude and
you really nailed the aesthetic and
everything thank you where did you film
it in Chicago uh in at the Den theater
we filmed it in Chicago awesome venue
we've heard it's incredible venue and uh
my fans actually broke the liquor record
Two Sold Out
shows of course could have told you that
yeah the writing was on the wall there
but it was great I obviously the other
scenes were filmed in LA but we shot for
four days and we wrote I I'm like well
we're going to set everything up let's
shoot some sketches and we originally
going to put the sketches make it really
like a Quinn Barton production where
after like 12 minutes like act one and a
couple sketches but everyone felt like
yeah this standup is strong just let the
stand up roll so at the end you'll see
like three or four sketches yeah yeah'
be oh you you Tagg them on yeah like
next week on bartnik oh that's awesome
oh that's cool that's really really cool
idea whose idea was it the whole thing
was my idea amazing dude so I just and
Bill I grew up on that television
exactly I mean that's the only shows I
still watch are basically like me TV
antenna
TV all those ones I watch Cojack the
untouchabl those are my the best one so
I wanted to do that and where's it's on
all things comedy YouTube All Things
comedy's YouTube page yes all things
comedy YouTube page great great uh
people over at all things comedy when's
the last time you've gotone to a fist
fight oh man that's it's been a while uh
you know cuz I I was just thinking about
that today I think if you get into a
fight after like you're in high school
there's a problem right like unless it's
like against basically I'll I'll get in
more almost fights because of my dogs
right right right like I'm in I'll be in
New York for four months in a relic
before the pandemic and never once have
a h word for anybody someone's car rolls
up quick on my dog it's like I'm gonna
kill everybody in the car right yeah
yeah cuz I feel like you're a guy who at
times well you probably did get into a
lot of fist fights you have you have a
guy reformed energy you know what I mean
by that I would describe you as a
Bruiser as a Bruiser yeah I'm not a good
technically sound wrestler I'm a brawler
brawler like I want you on my hockey
line oh exactly I always play defense
even though I was terrible skating
backwards just just I could punish
people you know I I basically you know
I've always kind of used my body for uh
my money you know either like either
either just bouncing or you know doing
other stuff so it's like you know that's
all I don't have too many skills though
I can a Manhattan and okay you know well
you're very tell some dick jokes that's
about that's why I got to do comedy what
else can I do every time I every time I
I I think about you or I see your name I
think about I don't I don't think it was
you that told me it was somebody who
told me that one I think it was
Pittsburgh Steelers you were in the park
lot it could be Pittsburgh Steelers or
Buffalo Bills game and you pissed out a
kidney stone oh that was at the Rose
Bowl yes
yeah and you and you didn't
go oh [__] that's one of the reasons why
I'm the rosebowl legend I have like five
rosebowl stories in tailgating that are
just Insanity because we we you know
I've heard that a kidney stone is the
most horrific pain a man can go through
and you pissed it out let it hit off the
back of the portter party and continued
hanging out at that game I pretty much
close to that story basically I you know
had like you know you start out like 600
in the morning so I had like 10 beers I
I had to suck it up usually I just wait
till everyone leaves the parking lot
then pissed by somebody's car and I
portapotty ruin my buzz like I I'll go
home
take sh Rolling Stones in Jesus Christ
like I'm not going to be in a port so
yeah' be tough who's following
who seriously I mean Jesus got to get
closer but you got to follow satisf
they're both opening they're both
opening for Taylor
[Laughter]
Swift but so I'm like I got I got to
suck it up and go and I'm literally just
in the portapotty imagine a porta the
sun beating down just for like I mean it
could have been it's probably 12 minutes
it felt like 6 hours wow and I just
couldn't you knew what was happening I I
I didn't know what was going on I'm just
like then I come back to the porter
party everyone's like you're green dude
I'm like I don't feel good and then and
I and then and my roseb friends are like
my best buddies like Burr and a couple
other guys that there like they usually
they've seen me messed up like we've
never seen you like this before and I
literally just like laying against a car
just you were in pain you were in real
pain oh my God where was the pain all
over the side of my body and just
just so sick I was like sick to death
and then I'm just I'm like I know if I
could just go to the bathroom I would
feel okay so then I'm just standing so
finally most of the people went in I
just went behind the car and just just
sat there sat there sat there sat there
and all of a sudden like I felt like
just the release of like a like just
like like like a balloon popped and I
literally swear at least in my mind I I
heard a pebble hit the side of a tire
cuz I know exactly I was pissing this
guy's tires and Bing that I was like and
I come back and they're like you okay
I'm like yeah I feel amazing now I went
into the game what do you understand how
crazy that is so like people would be
Hospital hospitalized they liking at the
child birth don't Sergio shakon is is is
a good friend of mine great comic um one
of the toughest guys I know outside of
you he and he had a kidney stone and he
was almost had to go to the hospital cuz
he was like I can't deal with this and
this guy used to beat up drug dealers
with his fists and and I'm like and so
for you to just walk back into a a a a
football game to me is nuts I I mean
just I'll be right back like you that
you could have been there went and got a
hot dog and and like a beer and come
back and that would have been the same
amount of time that you left and pass
the is it kidney or Gall kidney it was a
kidney stone what's the difference well
gallblader is in your in your gall and I
don't the thing with the gallbladder is
it's like a fake heart attack so a lot
of people they think oh I'm going to
have a heart attack and they go to the
hospital like no your gallbladder is
messed up oh you know passing a stone
with a a GF St KY stones and gall stones
are different organs
was that that did you [__] my dad hasn't
[__] in two and a half weeks so we're
waiting we're waiting for it oh my God
mixing mix in the salad buddy yes you
know go go to go to the Rose Bowl that's
what you get it out not a porta potty so
so you didn't know what was happening
while this was happening you didn't know
what it was no I mean I just felt
completely sick and it just like I mean
I couldn't go to the bathroom for I mean
imagine just you so what was running
through your head like what were your
guesses as to what was going on uh my
guesses were just
like I I I I was out of I was out of
guesses I just knew I had to go to the
bathroom really bad but I couldn't go
something was blocking right and you
were
inebriated no I had a good Buzz okay but
it was like it wasn't like holy [__] I
got to pee so bad cuz I drank beers too
yeah that too oh that sensation too well
so so think about that sensation if
you're drinking let's call 10 beers you
guys know I mean how much you have to
pee to not be able to get that out had
to be in just that right there the Panic
that would say I would have passed out
it might have been the thing that saved
you because you had such a powerful
stream backed up that helped you to
shoot it out it was a p i mean it was
just like it was I'm telling you it was
like someone turned on a SP it like yeah
like it would have like disect my God I
felt so good I felt I felt so I felt so
much better yeah you could have took
somebody's eye out I bet with that 100%
if you were in like an enclosed room you
would hear like dink dink dink dink dink
is that a kidney stone is that the
world's largest kidney stone bartnik you
think it was something like this oh no
no no no it was it was like the it was
like a size of like a baby tooth okay I
I have a 2-year-old so I I can you know
what I mean that little bit you know
when you say for the Tooth Fairy yeah
yeah but just that enough was enough to
cause you to you a guy who's as strong
as an ox to be like on the floor it
hurts I take a lot of pain between all
my surg I've had seven surgeries I had a
heart attack like I I never was in Jesus
Christ heart attack I was never even in
the NFL like there's no reason I should
have this many surgeries why did you
have a heart attack we didn't know you
had a heart attack right uh I had a this
is so funny cuz my heart was messed up I
I feel like I'm doing like a medic I
feel like I'm on the lifetime channel
I'm sorry I'm sorry I feel like such an
old man what happened this time it was
the AFC championships he he just went
out for a second had a came back in this
is the this is the podcast that all our
fellow podcasters moms Listen to We're
for the moms mom moms love me but now
because I'm past the daughter phase now
now now chicks are like yo yeah you you
remind me of my uncle a that's like I'm
done yeah you're done yeah
yeah so what so when did you have a
heart attack we didn't know anything
about well right before like like like
six weeks into the real P or like a
month into the real pandemic but I got I
had the I got I'm pretty sure I the real
pandemic yeah I'm pretty sure I had the
I'm pretty sure I had the OG uh the OG
Co cuz I was with Jimmy Big Balls
remember Jimmy Big Balls got he was in
the hospital for two weeks I I prayed
for him and he live because when I came
home with it shout out Jimmy Big out
Jimmy B when I came home with it I gave
it to ver I gave it to verie cuz he was
staying at my house and then he brought
it back to his family but the thing with
the heart though I just didn't feel good
for like two weeks but you know
obviously I Liv but the thing with my
heart was that whole fall my chest is
sore my chest sore my wife's like you're
you're you're you're doing karate with a
bunch of black belts that weigh 250 PBS
are kicking your chest four days a week
that's why that's why your chest hurts
I'm like oh okay there you go to New
York that was happening in addition to
you having the heart attack you already
having a mile heart and it kept kicking
that that was instead of thinking oh you
know what I'm 50 maybe I'm really should
have my heart checked right that then I
go uh so then I go to New York I'm and I
think I'm just sleeping on Gino's couch
crooked I'm like my chest still hurts
for like six weeks and then and then I
was home and then Friday night was a
Friday night I'm just like and I'm like
I can't do nothing I can't do nothing
and my wife's like you want to call the
ambulance and I'm like no cuz I just
Jimmy Big Balls just got out I'm like
I'm like going to the hospital and never
come out right right right right so I'm
like no and then I calmed down then my
we were still doing karate in my
backyard and drinking beers on the and
then my my Sensei is like we coming over
tomorrow go we can drink I ain't [__]
around I don't feel good and then Sunday
I had more another one and then Monday
my wife's said you're calling the doctor
I called the doctor because I'm make an
appointment for you I went and saw the
heart guy Wednesday I went in they
scoped me all out and that's it this is
you're you're you're a Marvel you're a
human Marvel he walked off a heart
attack I treat like an ice cream
headache
you you had a thre day extensive heart
attack that was jump started by black
belts kicking you in the chest yes you
waited you had it over the course of
three days you were having a heart
attack then you went in you got scoped
out and just left it was in it was
outpatient yeah well they had to see
what it was and basically I I I'll
confirm but so I don't say nurse is
giving you hate mail um I have what they
call coronary artery spasms which is
like heart attack is like you're clogged
mine is like my heart just gave out and
they could see a scar tissue around it
you know like when your leg cramps from
playing too much basketball that's
basically what happened to my heart it
just gave out okay but they sculpted you
they they cleaned you up and now you're
good heart back you know the biggest
thing was I got a catap machine now so I
don't wear my heart out constantly seap
the greatest thing I've been wearing it
for like 20 years now oh because I I'm
like oh my God I'd be so much further in
life if I wasn't tired all day it's an
amazing thing I know you didn't even
realize you had anything you thought you
were sleeping 8 hours every night I was
but I was I take 2our naps and it's like
you just you you're tired all day and my
snoring was legendary this is legendary
more legendary than your kidney stones
say if you listen closely you can still
hear
it so the cpat machine now you sleep
when you wake up you are rested I am
ready to rock and walk can you just
sleep like 4 hours just be ready to rock
and roll it's life changing cuz you
don't realize how much you're not
sleeping you too Tad machine changed
your life oh I couldn't even keep my
eyes open I I I was having trouble
driving cuz I was falling asleep like I
was getting tired behind the wheel and
class all that stuff and and then uh you
know I didn't want to do it I put it off
who wants to go to sleep with a freaking
phop pilot mask on every night you know
and then I went to the hospital and they
had this like fake bedroom or the the
Sleep Center and I slept there and they
were like 100% they were like yeah it's
like it's bad hello fresh America's
number one meal kit okay with hellofresh
you get Farm Fresh pre portion
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
trips to the grocery store count on
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and affordable that's why it's americ
hell fresh cuz you know what they do all
the shopping and meal planning for you
they're like my stepmom they do it all
ingredients arrive at your doorstep
pre-portioned and ready to cook along
with pictured step-by-step recipe cards
how easy is that they show you pictures
sou I know and by the way my fall
schedule which we just talked about is
jam-packed it is and hellofresh makes
whipping up a home-cooked meal I mean
come on let's be honest uh actually
doable they have quick and easy options
including 15minute meals and that's less
time than it takes to get the actual if
being honest and four baby you know me
with four they got a little p p
cheesecake p and pie cheesecake it's
it's I love pkin cheesecake I didn't
cook until I found hellofresh dude go to
hellofresh.com
heab and use code 50 hey bab for 50% off
plus free shipping let me say it yeah go
to hellofresh.com
heab and use the code 50 hey bab for 50%
off plus free shipping hello fresh
America's number one meal kit game
time game time uh we love the game time
app we use the game time app you got to
go to
gametime.com
gametime.co it's last minute tickets at
the best prices guaranteed lot of good
features views from your seats best
price guarantee you get uh easy to find
tickets for every kind of event in your
area they literally do the lowest price
guarantee and they prove it with that
because with the game time guarantee it
means you will always get the best price
if you find tickets in the same section
and row for Less game time will credit
you
110% of the difference that's absolutely
right uh it is and this Flash Deals is
like last minute deals and this is
something I didn't see but the Zone
deals is where you pick the section game
time picks the seats and that's going to
be an average of 20% savings every time
I love it take the guest work out of
take the guest work out of buying
tickets man and they got every sport
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater and more yes R find
tickets for us use the game time app if
you can't if we're sold out find the
tickets for us um right now all you have
to do is download the game time app
create an account and use the code hey
babe for $20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account
redeem the code h y BBE for $20 off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
so that I got it and I you know but I
it's annoying cuz we have to like we
perfect you travel with it it's like
dude now that those weekend carryon bags
become so tough for Real Estate that
that's so true oh my God that's why I
had to bring my rolling back this time I
hate a rolling bag in New York but it's
like or I can't bring my a second pair
of shoes something get sacrificed
something get sa I have the mini travel
one which is fantastic yeah but it's
still yeah oh I have I have that one too
but it still takes up enough where it's
like for a backpack it's that extra
level of like well now I can't bring
this y or I can't buy this and bring it
home or something like that you have to
take the CPAP machine out through uh
security if you don't have TSA or
whatever yeah right right no but I mean
you got to have TSA yeah but sometimes
they'll give you the thing of like shoes
fine take everything out still so the C
and then they want you to unzip it out
of the thing so everyone just stand
there you're take it out your laptop
you're unzipping the thing Just Hoses
everywhere you be like a [__] I don't
know I've never had to take I've never
had to take it out I but I also have the
the pre whatever so I don't know but
even when I didn't have all the BTS or
whatever that sign's closed which
usually like when you're really in a
hurry the pre-check isn't open I've
never had to show that you know okay so
when did you start getting on the cat
machine how long like a like a like a
two weeks after my heart attack they
rushed it through like this guy needs it
CU I still I mean I was feeling terrible
the best was recovering from it was like
they just gave me all these heart pills
and it's in the pandemic I had nothing
to do but just sit in my backyard and
drink beers and like listen to Tunes I
was like I'm alive listen the Almond
Brothers amazing yeah just it was like
little ecstasy like yeah you know and
then it really helped my pandemic
because I didn't really I felt like I
was like terrible until like July I only
had one month of freaking out we're like
what am I going to do am I funny
nothing's funny the world shut down
what's going on and then like Labor Day
happened the comedy club in San Diego
called me and said you want to be our
first headliner back I said sure Ventura
opened up at both outside shows but like
you know in their little section and
then we went to go smoke cigars meet and
bird and a couple other people at the
American Legion and I'm like you know
what I don't feel like smoking it's when
all the fires were in la oh yeah and
he's like man you still can't breathe
he's like come back East with me yeah
and then they built all these little
wood stocks around for Bill to perform
outside wow all through New England like
they're like hey here's a tent go
perform and we put people on the lawn
and then Florida opened up and then
Texas opened up so I never really had
that big like I been on stage in 3 years
you I only had like a month of realizing
it going yeah interesting did I catch
earlier that you said that your Sensei
and other black belts come to your yard
to train and then you also drink beers
that sound like the coolest thing I've
ever heard he's said Sensei call me up
all my black belt friends we go in my
yard we drink beers we smash freaking
you know well they're like black belts
and brown belts and I and I'm only like
a purple belt and they just like had a
nice big backyard so they can like train
and have a couple drinks that's pretty
cool that you that yeah it's like you're
in like it's it's like you just describe
when you're a kid what you think the
dream would be to do when you get older
like I'm going to learn karate and I'm
going my friends learn karate we're
going to go in my backyard just do
karate all day we'll just drink we'll do
karate it's just it's so funny like
someone calls the house and she's like a
he's in the yard doing karate with his
friends well it it it did kind of save
it did kind of save me mentally because
we live we moved out I'm a city kid we
move out to the suburbs and it's just
like then there's like nothing going on
and it's like they drive out 45 minutes
in the Hollywood every night just to
like hang out and do a 10-minute set you
know La no one's it's not like New York
people hanging out boozing you're going
for a slice you're doing this so I'm
just like you know it turns into The
Shining real quick where I
live so it's cool to have like three
blocks away is my Dojo where I go like
four days a week and you know just screw
around and hit the bag a little bit and
get you feel normal when did you start
up with this karate oh just like uh I
actually don't even do it anymore
because uh for many issues but uh I
don't know six six years ago oh wow it's
interesting yeah it's interesting too
like people like there's a story about
Anthony Bourdain became like a black
belt in Jiu-Jitsu like after his 50th
birthday it's like you think that you g
like I always thought by the way I want
to just say something because I said on
a podcast I forgot whose podcast I said
but I said I said listen if you're over
12 years old and you still do Jiu-Jitsu
you're a [__] loser and
and that's Heth martial arts mixed
martial arts yeah and obviously I was
kidding every day multiple times a day
grown men who are Jiu-Jitsu Masters are
like say that to my face I'm coming to
your show they are serious I do comedy
I'm joking I was just saying that my
kids do Jiu-Jitsu and it's fun it's nice
but I was kind of trying to say if I
didn't know Jiu-Jitsu by the time I was
15 I just wouldn't pick up Jiu-Jitsu but
I'm I'm was just doing comedy so there's
no reason to practice your Jiu-Jitsu on
me if you come to my
shows let's let that lie right there you
know it's funny whether they continue or
not I was just thinking that is so funny
yeah that's a people [__] kill they
they Crush every day in the DMS they
like want to kill me cuz I said you did
compare it to gymnastics what did I say
what do you remember what I said exactly
you said um jiujitsu is the new
gymnastics okay that it's like for like
little you were very disrespectful yeah
right I was very there was very to the
Jiu-Jitsu Community it something for
kids to do in between napping right
right whatever I said I think it was
funny but I I yeah yeah and so I I live
by the comedy of it I stand by The
Comedy of it do you know do you know
that whether they continue on with
jiu-jitsu or not like let's say Delila
she continues on with it or even not but
this is what made me think of it there's
going to be a day in your life it'll
it'll there will be a day where she
could take you out 100% isn't that crazy
100% she 30 30 years you're junior
junior and and you know you're guy she's
she's a female but there's still going
to be a day where you you can't talk
[__] to her or she will take you out the
take you down to Chinatown my daughter
can kick my ass really really yeah she's
two belts ahead of me and she's big and
strong and she is just focused and my
one black belt buddy John he's a black
belt in in in Jitsu and my Kempo Karate
and he boxes damn and he's a drinker he
always comes over and uh he'll get a
little Saucy with my daughter I'm like
John don't ruin your butt
yeah they always do some [__] and then
my and then I call my daughter the boou
and the boo will just like get him like
yeah the boo I like and it's like that's
it the boo got you I'm like don't ruin
your bus always get a coule pops and
then start scream around Boo and I'm
like she's going to ruin your Buzz dude
good old big black belt John but I think
it's perfect your daughter I think all
women should know how to defend
themselves yes all men should too but
it's not a big a deal but women should
know how to defend themselves 100%
that's why I have my daughter in J Jitsu
they don't love it as much as I was
hoping but I'm going to just keep
pushing them because that that's the
same thing I think it's like at least
know how to do something defend yourself
we're all wearing New Balances by the
way hey New Balance New Balance has made
the they i' I've said this before
they're they're catching up to Nike
probably not in sales but I'm just
saying a lot of people for the over 55
crowd no but now young everybody's got
new pip aren is aren't New Balances lit
with the kids I got new balance for many
many many many years though yeah I think
they picked up Jack Carlo as they their
face oh I've seen that ad yeah is that
what it was the best yeah yeah how long
youve been wearing New Balances my first
pair of New Balances probably I mean
it's got to be 20 plus years these the
end
look this one came with like 50
different ends and you could change the
colors you take the end off oh look at
that velcro tell the audio audience
what's going on I think this is a Ronnie
I just velcro I just uh I just undid s's
velcro shoe he's got velcro shoes like
he's an 8-year-old dude in ji- jit too
cuz it's only for
[Music]
kids you just you just turned on the
people that get turned on by sounds too
that okay ready for you people that do
the
a ASMR am this is for you ready put your
ear right up to the put on your
headphones here we go this is for you
the people that do ASM
rmsn okay that's to make up full all the
drilling there there you go construction
stopped I think oh my God people are
coming left and right right
nowag somebody definitely just blew a
load in like
Minneapolis how many different colors
they give you for the end uh it was like
good a good dozen plus cuz it's on cuz
it's or maybe like 10 but it's like uh
for both sides and then both shoes so a
cool stack of them I was like this is
fun did they sponsor you no oh no I just
you just bought them like that and they
came with all those ends what are they
574s I like them yeah this it's an older
shoe I don't know if it still exists but
that's what's you always as
[__] that's what sold me I had mine's
480 what number do you have bar I don't
know what numbers do you got 515 what
are the difference between all the
numbers no clue no clue nobody knows
secret sauce I love new bounces the
thing is they they make a statement the
the color schemes yes so I kind of just
like to have like a neutral color cuz I
could wear them a couple days in a row
I'm these guys that has like nine pairs
of shoes so I kind of like to have a
color that kind of goes with everything
sometimes like that green goes against
what I'm wearing but what what can you
do I I have my cat machine I can't bring
four pairs of
shoes yeah I feel like a nice when I'm
on the road I like to bring like just a
pair of black shoes cuz like you said it
goes with everything I also now I'm at
the point because we travel so much
where I used to try to bring three pairs
of shoes five different outfits I bring
one pair of pants three or four
different shirts one pair of shoes and
stuff to work out in and that's it and I
don't care if I wear the same two times
in a row [__] pictures I don't care I
stripped it down I wear the shoes on my
feet now that's it exactly and the one
one pair of pants one pair of shorts and
that's it and then three shirts and
sometimes I like I'm like if I if the
[__] hits the fan I'll wear the shirt
from the first day just to drive home or
to fly yeah who cares I I usually bring
a backup pair of pants if there's two
shows because you know I'm going to be
out boozing the night after so if you
spill something it's like I got to have
a backup I hear that I hear that I'd
rather I'll wash my pants in the sink
I've washed my pants in the hotel sink
man many times really oh yeah I've never
done that a single time really many
times oh yeah I always wash my I not
always but if I go out boozing or I have
a I get like ketchup on my pants from
like a brunch or something oh taking out
a stain is different I'll wash them in
the sink I pictured you H standing over
with like a washboard that's my dad my
dad saying something your dad's
Whispering something to me what are you
saying dad's just scream it you wash
your pants in the sink that's true I do
wash my pants in the sink I do wash my
pants in the sink yes my dad my dad's
confirmed the truth of
that let me ask you a question is this
over doing cuz you talking about
learning self-defense for my lady I I
get nervous so I got a pepper spray
right so that's no big deal she carries
pepper spray on her and she has the
pepper spray and it is what it is
recently I'm like what if the pepper
spray malfunctions what if uh it's some
guy and a big dude or something like and
the pepper spray doesn't you know bother
that person so I'm now in the process of
getting her stun gun wow now she told me
I'm crazy and that she's not going to
carry around a stun gun and it's it's
small and I said well why not like why
am I crazy like what if you you'll
hopefully you'll never need it but if
you ever did need it wouldn't you rather
have it than not I agree she's like I've
walked around my whole life without this
stuff now you want me to carry Peppers
spray and a stun gun I'm like yeah but
like I don't see the big deal but she
said I was going overboard we're living
in a more dangerous city than when she
was growing that New York has gotten has
returned to some previous danger as it
used to was I think she needs a Sun gun
d d do you think Sal girl needs a stun
gun yes or
no yes oh oh and that's coming Tony says
yes how's it I've never used a stun gun
is it easy to use I thought I was
getting her I thought it was a taser
that I was getting or like you know
shoot it and the things come out and
someone's
like Batman with like like you know when
they just crease up and then they just
Keel over I wanted that I wanted the big
stuff you know I thought she was like
but no this is just one of those like
like like incapacitate you like so I
don't know I I haven't seen it I'm
getting so it's like a NCO razor but you
touch someone in the here's the thing I
thought it was going to be I was ready
to put down some money for this I
thought it was going to be like a gun
few hundred you want a good one not like
a sharp verion I I have one in the
process of of getting it I have someone
delivering it and uh it was like3 $35
$40 $35 or I'm like is this thing like
is that a piece of [__] yeah like that
doesn't sound like it would be a good
one I feel like for a stun gun should'
be like you know at least 119 bucks yeah
$119.99 easy yeah here we go here this
guy's going to describe um it seems like
stuff to get pretty
close
yeah so
um one is okay did you get it the pink
one no that looks like a literally like
a razor yeah yeah shave your face with
it
yeah manscaping and
self-defense she's gonna have to Dem
she's gonna have to demonstrate
yeah this looks
hard spray a dog what about the
[Music]
sack if you're hitting the sack with
that
thing you're getting really close 5
seconds I think pepper spray is easier
than this I like pepper spray but you
need 5 Seconds of it it says I like her
to have the
option i' like her to have the option
yeah have her pepper spray spray let her
she'll determine maybe if she has if if
he's pepper sprayed then he can sit
there for 5 seconds right I think you
hit it's a onew com with pepper spray
and then stun
him yeah that's what I think that's what
I would do I would spray first and then
stun yeah spray then stun it happen so
quick I and then sign up for jiujitsu
Jitsu ex talk mon I'm going to find a
video that is not going to disappoint to
I witnessed somebody's shoes get ripped
off them on the train the other day on
the way to Radio City yeah these two
kids got jumped on Canal Street and they
didn't have pepper spray or stun guns no
and the other team had knives wow yeah
yeah I I I think that um I think that
most times when you're getting robbed or
something like that the people who are
doing it are obviously not in the right
state of mind but if you hit them back
if you hit them back I think a good
percentage of them let's say 70%
probably just will run away they don't
want the fight because most people are
going to get hit and just cover up but
if you just take a few swings back you
know I don't know I think that even most
crial would be like I don't want to deal
with this guy I don't have you ever been
robbed uh not physically robbed just
digitally just robed your
dig no like my house has been robbed a
couple times I haven't been I have never
been held up KN on but you weren't home
no I got the it'd be a stupid move to
try to hold you up pimp I'm sending you
right now that I want you to put yeah I
just um but I mean like I'm not gonna
die for a lot of things you yeah I don't
care about anything it's like you want
to steal my Just my kids and my family
but like you want to take my sneakers
you want to take my wallet take it all I
don't care take my car take it I don't
give a [__] that's what I mean it's not
worth [__] D pleas please take it
yeah it's it's like these possession
what is this now before you hit play I
can't believe I found this on my phone I
saw this one time I was shocked beyond
belief no pun intended and I saved it
because I had to show other people I
don't know who sent this to me or how I
got it but and I cannot believe that it
took that quick to pull it up cuz I
haven't watched it in years but check
this video up babe this podcast episode
sponsored by better help let me ask you
a question babe do you ever feel like
your brain's getting in its own way 247
365 every second even right now yep I do
too you know what you should do we all
know what we should do what's good for
us but we can't just do it it's like
something's blocking us we can't do it
but therapy is the thing that helps you
figure out what's holding you back so
you can work for yourself instead of
against yourself that's right and I'm
just wearing these because they're
prescription not because I'm too cool if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try we say this all the
time it's entirely online if you don't
know it's designed to be convenient
flexible suited to your schedule you
fill out a brief questionnaire and you
get matched with a therapist you could
switch therapists anytime and no
additional charge uh they've been with
us uh since the beginning and the reason
they're with us I do believe still is
because people have been you know you
know going to better help because of our
podcast 100% we're the reason why
they're still in business it's official
and and and you know and even my father
tampaon had him on the podcast he went
to better help I got him hooked up with
there he hadn't taken a crap in 3 weeks
next thing you know he's crapping like a
2-year-old now because of the good
people at betterhelp he didn't realize
it was a mind block it was a mind butt
block which happens to us sometimes make
your brain your friend with better help
yes visit betterhelp.com /ab today get
10% off your first month that's better
help
hp.com heab VOR guys VOR has over three
300,000 bookable travel experiences in
over 190 countries they offer things
from simple tours to Extreme Adventures
and uh even the niche stuff interest
interesting stuff in between Vier is the
place to go to book memorable travel
experiences if if you're like me uh when
I'm traveling and it's for vacation I'm
always like where do I go to find out
the cool things to do I kind of go to
the concierge or I try to get like a
magazine uh of that
but this is even better you go right to
it and there is a list of things that
you could do so it's immediate so it's
good to have that app downloaded because
it takes all the work out of figure out
what are the cool things to do in
whatever City you are okay
um their travel experiences have
millions of real traveler reviews so you
have the information you need to book
the best activities for your trip and
that's another thing if you land in
Seattle and you go on V and you look at
10 things you could also also look at
how people felt about that so you feel
like you're making an educated decision
in case you're on the fence really cool
um Chris uses it all the time so uh I
use it once in a while but this guy he
he was using it before they were a
sponsor so if that tells you anything uh
there's always flexibility and support
with free cancellation payment options
and a 24/7 service download the Vador
app now and use the code Viator 10 for
10% off your first booking in the app
one app over 300,000 travel experiences
you'll remember do more with
VOR can you get a little volume wait
pause pause pimp I don't want it to
happen hold on okay start from the
beginning give us volume yeah I I I I
challenge you guys to not have a
reaction sry from the beginning all
right let's
[Music]
go
you're not
[Music]
ready what
the
what oh my
God you have to
describe holy [__] you have to explain
to the audience what just happened all
right I I someone sent me this and I to
this day I want to put a team of people
together to investigate cuz I don't
understand what's going on it's a woman
dancing in what looks like her own
bedroom to some R&B she's really feeling
it and then out of nowhere She lays on
her bed on her back spreads her legs
pulls out a stun gun and stuns her own
vagina and knocks herself unconscious
she's wearing clothes and she then
literally
seizes she starts having a seizure and
she just she just she stiffens up and
she just falls off the bed stiff and she
shocked her privates but honestly like
something like that it's like wait who
makes me want to buy a stun gun
yeah that's a better ad than the chicken
that do the
sweater that should be sab's new ad
right there just like you know multiple
uses like explain to me your explain to
me how you think that came to be I think
that she's a very very horny person and
I think that she was just looking for
just another way to you know climax ah
she's videoing it and she's dancing
normally she's just dancing and she's
feeling it and she's alone the but but
it just it's wild to me like she how
would you ever commit that to tape I
mean and then and then it's and put it
out there and how do you how do you how
do you realize that editor you stun
yourself there how do you try that for
the first time to stun yourself and then
build up such a tolerance that you could
hold the stun gun on it while you ride
in pain before you stiffen up and almost
pass out yeah that was like a Fear
Factor test like can you last more than
6 seconds with this in your cooch yeah
also didn't it I I didn't know they
usually have lights on them too that was
kind of neat it was bedazzled it was
like the shock that was the actual like
uh like the shock like the electricity
she she electrocuted she took some volts
man she took she took some volts and she
took some volts and what's funny to me
is like when you're watching it you
don't think that you have no idea that
that's what she's going to do she's just
dancing and then she just pulls it out
and does it out of nowhere still to this
day one of the one of the crazi things
I've ever seen in my entire life the
video you sent me yesterday you dm' me
yesterday with the the first
pitch but we can't play that right I
don't know I mean I know we was that on
Instagram yeah that was a good video
when he sent me a picture you've seen it
you guys have probably seen it before
when the guy blows the first pict pitch
so bad he hits the cameraman in the nuts
yeah and then the organ goes Dam the
funniest part is the organ man I never
even thought about I never even listen
to the organ cuz you just yeah guy and
yeah this one pippy just play this quick
and put it up full blast listen to the
organ in this folks all the way that's
this is the funny part of this all right
Jordan fire in
there
just outs he definitely did that on
purpose right the guy oh or guy give
that organ guy a raise a raise yeah
that's so fun I mean this is a bot first
pitch all those old guys watching guy
hles
away and he's like got hit right who is
that guy do we know who this a chance to
I think he was a fan that had some typ
he overcame some type of uh illness or
whatever and they and so he's just a fan
you guys have thrown first I've never
thrown the first pitch you guys have
thrown first pitch I've been I've been
asked to and I have so far decided not
to do it you got to I mean you got to
warm up though right you do you have
warm you have to warm up I I don't love
the possibility of I mean on a regular
day I would throw it but the I would
definitely not something would happen
where I would I be and I'd be one of
those people that in a long list of
people that here's what you do here's
what you do you going to get Flack for
this I got Flack for this but this what
no when we did it when we did it at City
first of all I had my daughter run out
with me so they get sympathy right there
and then what I did was the the guy they
gave me the ball they gave me the ball
and then I stepped off the mound and I
stepped in front of the mound and I
threw a perfect strike but not from the
mound okay and then I then we threw a
first pitch out somewhere else at
Chicago and I bounced it off home plate
or was it or was it the Brooklyn
Cyclones you warmed up at the Cyclone
game and then went to the but then we
threw out the first pitch for the cubs
too how that Chicago weren't you with
did you come with me to Chicago Theater
I bounced that one off home plate look
you want to reach but bouncing is not as
bad as like uncatchable right hitting a
cameraman is worse than
bouncing like I'm just afraid like I
just don't want to be on that list of
people but I should do it but do you
guys think you could kick a field goal
no no no I can't no way from how far any
length you you want no way I don't I I
don't think I think that's probably the
hardest thing you don't think like maybe
maybe like the maybe like the five yard
I think I think to even get it that high
I think that's a skill that people you
have to have that skill yeah I mean if I
had to the Tom Dempsey like half a foot
steel plate shoe maybe but just a normal
like shoe no way this past weekend I
think somebody hit a 62 uh the NFL
player yeah they just no I I'm saying
I'm just saying it's amazing they just
they just made it but remember the guys
would kick Barefoot yes those lunatics
be like snowing like who thought I'd be
better with kicking this barefoot dude I
cannot believe the Cardinals beat the
Cowboys I know dude it makes yeah it's
it's it's uh that was it 62 dude what
about the dolphin scoring 70 points and
they took a knee or they could have
broke the all record what you think
about the knee you know what I could
have went either way on that one because
look you you're going to let up now you
could have let up at 55 you know like
you still went to 70 I mean I granted it
was like you're not going to give the
ball over and this is the end of the
game but like I think you think he
should have went for it cuz why not let
your team go and say they have the
alltime record right I know you it's the
alltime not like the single season the
all time they theyve been playing
football for like 120 years what is the
all time record is it 71 70 7 I think
it's 7 whatever it was the field goal
would have been the alltime record W it
was 72 72 okay they had 7 so the field
goal would have broke it by one now I
mean let me ask you this what did they
really do I know it's out of etiquette
and like kind of professionalism respect
and everything but like they could have
kicked that field goal yeah I agree with
right so they could have kicked it so
everyone knows they could have kicked it
right they're there they they could have
kicked it so the team's not like we did
any better just because they didn't kick
that just that they're the footnote now
in the books you know what I mean so
they spared them to as being a statistic
but really the morale is already
depleted when you when you start to hit
the high six0 I got to be honest with
all the evolutions in sports with
baseball changing and everything we
should be done with the field goals in
football it's not football make field go
kicking another sport that's what Larry
David said I think did he say that yeah
make field go kicking another sport
don't I just just think football is
football score the touchdowns safeties
you can get points that way fine but the
kicking is like why is the foot why is
the part why is this part of the sport
what you what do you great I would love
for them to get rid of punting as well
so they always had to go for it on
fourth down I love that I just think it
would be such a different game and more
interesting game because because listen
they put they put they changed baseball
rules radically I mean the Extra Inning
game now Guy starts on second the pitch
clock so those are big big the the no DH
in the National League uh in the uh DH
is in both leagues now pitchers don't
batt like those are radical rule shifts
they could shift they could do that in
the NFL but the NFL's attendance isn't
dway dwindling like MLB they need to do
something nobody was watching this is
still making money they should just all
play first team to 70 every game yes no
punts first team 70 every game every
single game I tell you I think that's a
kicker in football and I could be wrong
we should ask a kicker I know but I
think that might be the most Posh job in
in all professional you miss oh that's
true that's true it's a heavy dut it's
like the closer basball disagree but I
mean I mean like you're not getting beat
up you could play to you could kick
balls to you're like 50 years old I
think the closer in baseball is more
Posh you get paid big money the kickers
don't get paid big money until you blow
it who had a better life and than
Mariana
all the money all the fame unanimous
Hall of Famer
pitched about 6 minutes a day yeah
pitched about six minutes starting
pitchers have a real plush job there's
not really any pressure and you work
like five every five days yeah you know
after you pitch whether you get knocked
down the first inning a pitch or no
hitter you can get [__] wasted that
night you are not going in the game for
five days all they do is they they like
they they ice then like the next day
they run the Outfield the next day they
throw a little next day they rest next
day they pitch they gotta go like five
innings nowadays used to be they have to
go like seven or eight now they got like
five give up a hit couple runs that's it
it's true but if you if you if you
Whittle down how much a kicker is on
field two I mean he's he's he's kicking
once a week and he's kicking maybe you
know he could kick anywhere from zero
zero to five times he kicks his leg and
that's it what do you think's the worst
job the worst job in sports being a
catcher in baseball or running back in
football o which one one sucks worse uh
cuz those two are the wor they're the
worst on it used to be when we were kids
running back was like the number one
position to have in football remember
all the stars were running backs Smith
and then they just wore them out and
then they realized hey we can just get
anyone that can run kind of fast for
three
yards um I I I think being a catcher is
a no- win situation man ah dude that's
that's three they used to call the the
the the pads the tools of ignorance yeah
yeah yeah I mean it's think about it
right it's 162 games it's three and 1/
half hours a game squatting squatting
and you're you and you you're the that's
every you're that's every one of them
yeah foul balls off your mask your nuts
yes all the pads it sucks also just the
level of focus you need to have as a
pitcher and catcher not that you don't
have to have it as another you know but
like I mean a right fielder like he's
not he's not locked in he should be but
I'm saying like the catcher needs to be
locked there there's 90 mph balls he's
calling the game hurt your hand if a
guy's throwing 100 miles hour hurt your
hand every time you you have to call
every p you have to know you have to
think the whole game I'll tell you I
just thought of it the easiest job in
sports DH yes DH is the easiest that's
the you get to do exactly what you want
to do anyway just hit just hit just no
one wants to play the field yeah yeah
just hit they say so the 20 worst jobs
in sports pimpy pulled it up we have the
football laundry specialist this is
number 20 um teammate of AJ presensi oh
okay yeah I guess I guess they didn't
like it yeah oh Sports blocks what's
number one let's go to number one I like
to see what just what do they think the
worst one is Yankee Stadium custodian is
number two youth football ref yeah that
does suck a youth football ref yeah now
you is your daughters old enough to play
sports my my 8-year-old plays uh she she
was on uh uh track but then she played
basketball but she didn't like
basketball so my daughter was pretty
good at basketball and I just re really
really really just didn't say a thing no
right yeah it's just like because I
first of all to the coaching hey I can
coach my kid and like a couple of her
friends yeah I don't like everybody's
kid man that's just so God bless these
people and then the referees they why
they making eight bucks an hour like
what you to get on these people and it's
like it's it's I mean it's women it's
girls basketball it's like we can all
just relax let the ladies play they lose
their minds it's like they're 13 years
old this like for the Middle School
semi-finals take it easy oh yeah my
niece plays flag football and it's
comptitive and she's on traveling teams
and she's like a quarterback and
everything and I she they've had
instances where like the two other like
the coaches are like NE near brawling
not even the parents near brawling on
the on the field yeah yeah it's wild
it's it's it's dumb I I don't I don't
I'm not that kind of parent I'm like
whatever my kids want to do I'm like
dude like you said we're all kids we're
all going to be in Chinese prison camps
anyway what's the difference you know
what's the difference
man you're wearing a quartero had too I
didn't notice this oh yeah yeah you were
wearing it last episode no I switched we
tried to we tried to switch so it
doesn't feel like the same our last
guest Rob eer uh from the uh from The
Sopranos was wearing a corduroy San
Diego Padres hat I thought it was nice
that's what we're going to get to in
baseball corduroy uniforms o uh's the
king of the Corduroy corduroy King isn't
that what tried to do on
Seinfeld he tried to do all cotton he
tried to do all cotton and then every
and they all shrank and then everyone
was on the field
uncomfortable Joe Let's uh what do you
need to plug I know the special and
everything else you wanted do uh the
special on all things comedy bartnicka
killing in Chicago thank you guys for
showing it I hope you guys enjoy it I I
I I'm really happy with it thank God
maybe the worst when you're not happy
with it and as far as movies go I'm in
uh old dads with Bill bur Bobby
carnavali low ke I have a great scene
with Bobby carnavali and he was my
favorite actor under 70 oh that's
awesome bar of the he does look like a
like a fun dude he's the coolest guy man
he's the coolest guy so we got that and
if you like hockey listen to my podcast
Puck off Puck off baby great name and
then and then it's killing in Chicago
and they can find it on all things
comedy's YouTube page I'm Joe bartnik if
you there's a link on my website if it
gets confusing there you go baby there's
my dad throwing out the garbage right at
the end of the podcast right at the
church I just want to thank you guys so
much for having me on course thank you
for coming on man you're great than you
for coming on so much fun I love
catching I love learning about your
heart attack I know I I I can do five
hours on just all my medical
problems well Do's open anytime you want
to come back baby love you buddy love
you love you
too don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
bab hey bab hey bab hey Bab